hello everyone and welcome to the game i
originally wanted to show in the
previous video but uh on you know it's
nice when things work out uh it's johan
harterson like in the previous video uh
i slammed the grandmaster versus danish
grandmaster mats anderson and now you
guys know why uh this whole
mixup came to be uh but we are showing
the game uh nonetheless and you guys
will really enjoy this one if you don't
know what uh happened in it so let's
dive straight into it there's a quite a
lot to enjoy uh here with the white
pieces opens with d4 and i apologize for
not having a better photo of maz
anderson it's uh
i really couldn't find one and it
doesn't help that he shares the name
with a well-known football player so
that also makes it a bit trickier to uh
to search for for images uh so apologies
for that but uh you know yeah as usual
we are here for the moves uh so d4 uh we
have d5 now uh
c4 going for the queen's gambit and now
d captures on c4 accepting the queen's
gambit so we have e3 uh opening up an
attack on the c4 pawn knight to f6 and
now just bishop captures in c4 so the
old variation of the queen's gambit
accepted we have e6 and the knight to f3
now we have c5 striking in the center so
this is all very well known in both of
them of course no uh theory on this
probably uh 20 moves deep yeah so here
we have castles a6 and bishop back to d3
as you know that b5 is coming at some
point uh instead of bishop to d3 d
captures and c4 is considered the
absolute main line today but uh
heretrason prefers the older bishop to
d3 we have knight beat to d7 and the
queen to e2 now we have b5 now black
going for full expansion on the queen
side uh a4 challenging the setup and now
c4 challenging the light square bishop
here bishop to c2 and now bishop to b7
so black can be very happy uh he
still has the uh the pawn here and uh he
he managed to develop the light square
bishop so e4 white grabs the full center
bishop to e7 and now bishop to g5 so
nothing new here this has all been
played many many times uh castles knight
b to d2 both players just continue
developing pieces h6 and now bishop to
h4 and now there are some games that
reach this position knight to the h4 uh
night h5 is a known move trying to trade
off the bishop here also rook to e8 is a
known move but here we have queen to b6
and now it is as of move 14 that we have
a completely new game so okay rook after
d1 uh white wants to put rooks on most
likely uh either the dnc file or he
plans to open up the position here maybe
trade off the rook here but the this
rook is coming to d1 rook f2 e8 uh and
now uh pawn to e5 trying to trade off
the dark square bishop knight to d5
bishop captures an e7 knight captures
and now as we freed up the e4 square
knight to e4 and you can see that the
knight is controlling some very very
important squares here and black does
not want this knight to come for example
to d6 with stamp on the bishop so bishop
to d5 first and okay knight to d6 and
now we have rook back to f8 as the rook
here is attacked rook to f8 and now rook
to a3 we are going to move the knight at
some point and then the rook will be
shifted to the attack maybe via the g3
square so here f5 uh black is saying
okay we're closing up the position we
don't have to worry about the bishop
here but we've weakened the g6 square
it's a trade-off and black doesn't
really have all that much to choose from
however f6 maybe would have given him uh
some more idea says uh you can always
advance it to f5 but once it's on f5 you
can no longer place it on f6 so maybe f6
here but okay knight to h4
we have knight to c8 of course this
knight is not remaining here forever
knight captures on c8 rook f captures in
c8 and now we finally win the g6 square
so knight to g6 now we're threatening
knight to e7 to pick up the rook here so
queen back to d8 guarding the e7 square
and now rook hold the weight to g3 so
okay now all of this has been planned
knight to f8 we want to kick away this
knight from g6 or trade it and harterson
says nope this knight is much much
better than this knight so we're going
to keep it for now
and now rook to rook to a7
this is a wonderful defensive resource
by anderson as
a lot of people often
forget about this resource so whenever
there's a really tricky position that
you have to defend us
it's easy to miss this resource but it's
uh the rook on the seventh rank is just
a remarkable not just a remarkable
attacking piece but also a defending
piece when you're playing black so queen
to d2 uh and now we have king to h8 if
the knight moves queen captures an h6 is
uh very annoying so you do not want your
king on g8 so king to h8 and now h4 this
looks like a free pawn but not really
because we are we are gonna win upon uh
in the center of the board once the
knight captures the bishop for example
if queen captures here we just capture
on d5 and then we pick up the f5 pawn
and we have a nice past e pawn so
instead after h4 we have rook to d7 now
the rook is defending the bishop so we
are considering queen captures here but
now uh the rook is no longer controlling
the a file so here we have h5 now not
allowing the queen to capture it and the
queen to h4
so while this is a very impressive
square for the queen it's also not that
clear what the queen is doing there uh
okay it's paralyzing the knight if the
knight moves we're going to capture on
h5 but other than that not all that much
so white goes for a captures and b5 a
captures and now rook back to a3 now
controlling the uh the a file as the
rook left the uh the da file by playing
rook a7 rook to d7 so here before
challenging the rook now comes rook to
a5 and now c3
b3 would have been uh a bit more more
clean but uh c3 is what was played in
the game uh and that uh allows the white
uh to to do the next thing bishop b
captures in c3 b captures attacking the
queen queen to e3 now we have to keep
the queen here as the knight has to be
defended now comes the bishop back to b7
to and not allow any any trade anytime
soon and did not rook back to a3 so now
how is black to defend the c3 pawn we
are attacking it twice we might play
rook to c1 attack it once again move the
bishop or maybe even rook to d3 pick up
the pawn uh this is how anderson does it
he plays rook d to c7 now we have rook
to c1 and queen back to e7 uh and then
now rook to b3 the rook here is attacked
so the queen is being remaneuvered with
tempo so rook to b3 queen to d7
and now rook to b6 and this rook to b6
is an incredibly strong move as you'll
see and after rook to b6 there really
isn't all that much uh
for black to try here what do you play
uh here bishop back to a8 was played uh
you do not want it here as a target if
the
position opens up but now comes bishop
to b3 and how are you defending this
pawn now the problem is uh if you go
back just bishop to c6 that's a that's
weird you just give up the c3 pawn so of
course you're not gonna do that so how
can you defend it it's being attacked
three times it's defended only twice if
you play something like rook to e8 then
again rook captures in c3 we are
defending the rook now only once so here
rook the c6 is played it makes sense to
trade off the rooks but now comes bishop
to a4 uh what do you do here well the
whole plan was queen to d8 now we offer
a a
a trade rook for rook bishop captures on
c6 queen captures on b6 bishop captures
an a8 rook captures an a8 and now a
queen captures on c3 so now we picked up
a pawn and it's a it's a fairly clean
pawn at some point the d5 will be played
and we will have created a past e pawn
so here rook to d8 we have to stop the
advancement of the of the d-pawn now
comes rook to d1 white will prepare of
course this advance we have queen to b7
guarding the d5 square and now g3
uh you have to uh defend the knight a
little bit and also to give your king a
free a couple of three squares because
maybe queen to e4 in the future could
come with an attack on the knight so it
makes sense to do this before advancing
the pawn we have king the g8 stepping
out of any any future check so now the
knight will be able to move you don't
have to worry about knight g6 check
queen to c4 again putting more pressure
on the spawn and also adding another
attacker to the d5 square rook the c8
now chasing the queen away queen to d3
and now queen to c7 uh and now well you
could play d5 at any point it could have
been played uh
you know in the past ten moves probably
at any point but uh heretrust wants to
fully prepare it so here rook to a1 uh
we have queen to b7 and now comes pawn
to d5 finally and okay you don't want to
allow advancing the pawn or maybe even
just capturing so he captures on d5 we
have queen captures on f5 and now d4 uh
anderson also starts advancing his pass
spawn now comes e6 and here rook to e8
now taking care of the e7 square
we have rook to d1 going after the
d-pawn here and now uh the problem is
you can't really defend this pawn
it's uh very hard to uh to do that
because if you move the queen anywhere
from the seventh rank uh just queen f7
will pick up the rook so that's a
problem so here knight the h7 is played
uh black gives up the d4 pawn in order
to
mobilize his knight rook captures on d4
and now knight to g5 and it's a it's a
pretty good trade-off considering the
position because now you always have
this knight to f3 check and white really
has to worry about this so rook to d7
attacking the queen and now the question
is what do you play here uh here queen
to c6 was played if you go knight to f3
check right away we can just play pretty
much anything king to g2 and even though
you are allowing this fork knight stage
for with a double check for example king
h2 there isn't all that much for you to
do here because after knight captures an
f5 rook captures on v7 you're still down
two pawns the pass bone is protected so
not a lot of fun so after rook to d7
queen to c6 was played and this is the
position why we are showing this game
because it's a really a spectacular one
unfortunately the best part of the game
did not actually happen in the game but
that's where you guys come in you will
help uh
finish this sort of an immortal
while i while i give you a couple of
seconds so
best move for white
what can white play here
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not just finding a
spectacular continuation for white but
also the only winning idea for white
here and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is queen to f7
check we have to sacrifice the queen
here however it's only a temporary
sacrifice because we will also win
black's queen here so you absolutely
have to capture the queen if you don't
capture the queen uh the king just moves
and we just pick up the g7 pawn with
checkmate as the rook also helps out
with with the attack here so this would
have been forced e captures on f7 with
check forking the king and the rook and
after king to f8 we don't capture the
rook but rather knight the g6 check and
now the black king has no squares
the e7 and f8 squares are covered by the
knight and of course the g8 square is
covered by the pawn so the only legal
move for black is to capture the knight
queen captures h captures and you have
this position where black is without
moves black of course would have to move
the rook rook e8 but now and that's
pretty much it for black the king can
never move for the rest of the game as
long as this rook remains on the seventh
rank uh and this rook can never move
from the uh from the eighth rank because
we just played rook 8 czech king here
and we promoted this pawn to a queen so
here it would be very boring to watch
this game or very enjoyable uh depends
on how you you know consider chess
because now white would just bring his
king up the board start pushing these
pawns and win the game easily as black
is without moves black can pretty much
just play rookie rugby rookie rugby
and so on so that was the winning idea
here however
it did not happen in the game in the
game as this pawn is attacked three
times of course you have to do something
about this uh e7 was played and this uh
simply will not to do uh here e7 was
played probably thinking that knight to
f3 is not as great of a resource as as
it actually is because if um uh
realized that knight f3 was such a great
resource he would have found this queen
to f7 idea but now after knight to f3
check it's just uh it's just a draw
because now king f1
knight to h2 with check king back to g1
knight f3 check king to h1 now even
going for this uh allowing knight stage
for check uh but um it doesn't really do
all that much because if you play knight
to h4 check we can just play queen d5
check and now force a queen trait here
and after queen captures knight captures
uh the knight to defend the pawn uh rook
here will i mean it it's just complete
sorry it's just completely winning for
white so instead after king h1 knight
the e5 was played or now opening up a
discovery and going after the rook here
so you have to block with the rook rook
to d5 and not rook captures on e7 and
now the pawn got eliminated pretty much
for nothing
and now the game is still better for
white but it's not easy to play king h2
was played now knight back to f3 with
chuck king h3 knight g5 check even king
to g4 and now queen to a8
uh keeping an eye on the back rank not
allowing any rook to d8 ideas so queen
to d3 going after rook to d8 to win the
black queen now comes queen to c8 to
check we have king back to h4 now comes
rook to e8 and now there simply is no
way for white to threaten any more ideas
as well black defended very very solidly
white is still up upon so of course
white will try but it was not enough to
to win the game uh more moves were
played of course this only move 63 and
the game lasted for 89 moves but
we can show it okay queen b3 or
threatening some discoveries king to h8
rook to b5 now yeah and now queen to d8
threatening some discoveries here so
queen to d5 offering a queen trade and
the black of course declines as black
has the the initiative here so queen to
f5 again offering a queen trade now
queen a1 going for some back rank ideas
knights the g6 check with king the g8 97
check trying to get to the rook to
capture the knight so we can go for
rugby to check but just king goes back
knight goes back with knight g6 check
king g8 now rook to b1 attacking the
black queen queen to d for check now
comes f4 attacking the knight and the
knight to f3 with check king g4 knight
h2 checking h3 knight to f3 and now
knight to e7 with check again trying to
uh give up the knight but of course king
to h8 and now comes knight to g6 with
check here white actually had solid
chances to play this for a win with king
to g2 as uh it would not allow this one
this knights to remain here but after
knight the g6 he repeated the position
king g8 uh rook to b7 now
now it's uh very very clean for black we
have queen to c4 now going after this
queen to f1 which would be of course
impossible if king to g2 was played
knight to e7 check again going for the
same idea king h8 knight to g6 check
king to g8 queen to b5 now
offering a queen trade while preventing
queen to f1 and now queen the e6 check
king g2 attacking the knight 91 check we
have king to h2 knight f3 check king to
g2 knights the e1 check king h2 now
queen to a2 with check king h3 now queen
to g2 with check but after king to g4
queen of three check king h3 queen to
each one check king the g4 queen f3
check h3 and he was in this position on
move 89 that the players agreed to a
draw or rather it's a draw by threefold
repetition so uh quite an unnecessary
game uh if you if you think about it but
a beautiful beautiful position after
this rook attacked the queen and uh of
course knight to f3 we've shown that it
doesn't work after queen to c6 uh queen
to f7 check would have been uh
definitely one for the books and the one
that uh i'm sure he attracts song is
very very uh sad that he missed uh
during the actual game
uh so yeah that's probably what happened
he he probably thought that even this
resource of knight to f3 check was not
enough for black to
survive this and then maybe he stopped
looking uh but if he
if he saw uh cleanly that it it uh
provided black with at least a draw then
of course he would have looked deeper
and queen to f7 would have been revealed
but uh i mean such a such a beauty we
can uh check it out one more time so
forced force this is force this is force
knight g6 is forced uh everything is
forced queen captures this force and now
this is black just resigns here and here
black would just i mean in the old days
like 150 years ago uh black would uh
after this queen to f7 a check black
would just get up in the leave from the
board without saying anything to anyone
no comments he would just you know
disappear and that would be it so
sad that it didn't happen but that's why
we have these videos you know to show a
few few variations that never took place
on on the board and then we can enjoy
them after the game was played
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and uh
as usual the the best part of the game
is very rarely uh you know played in the
actual game so i hope you enjoyed that
as well uh i would like to thank usfd
efri elias fine lionel alexandrino
lb for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and we're gonna check up on
a few more games from this wonderful
tournament so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day